denn ich muss dir erzählen ja mach
schneller ich möchte eigentlich nach
hause
mein vater der delikte zu uns kurz
überlegt sie könnten teil 70 kilo
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen ip
video leute wie ihr vielleicht wisst
habe ich früher hilfen videos zusammen
mit meinem bruder gemacht der aber vor
einiger zeit gesagt sebastian ich habe
da keine lust mehr drauf von dann habe
ich natürlich gesagt max klar du musst
nicht dabei sein wenn du nicht willst
aber ich habe gehört dass wir heute
einen anderen gast vorbei ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wert ist
aber wir haben gas treten sie bitte ein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
krimi ich würde sagen verkörpert wir
haben heute wieder sehr wertvolle
hinweise für euch das machen wir der
folge verbotene liebe mein vater ist ein
nazi
meine freundin geflüchtet damit ist ein
problem das wir alle sehr gut kennen
bevor wir anfangen ich hatte nicht mal
die mühe gegeben irgendwie eine
beschreibung zu schreiben
kromi ist an diesem gespräch hätten
befinde mich aktuell noch annette
charakterentwicklung
übrigens ich habe heute um mal angerufen
es schon wieder gesund
dieser stelle haben schon zu ersten
beiden protagonisten ich glaube das ist
irgendein mädchen was irgendwo rolle
spielt in diesem video und links daneben
haben wir ja in welchen deutschen
musiker sich diese person nach belieben
sollte gut frage ich habe schon mal die
kommentare angeschauten alle schreiben
einfach dass der aussieht wie kapital
wird sich aber im laufe der zeit zeigen
ob es tatsächlich kapital preiswertesten
sven unkontrollierte
[Gelächter]
dort sind es gerade prächtig
restaurierte hat eigentlich so ring aber
das ist so eine gurke geschnittene eine
ganze szene aus deutschland der capital
bank seine schwester zwei wochen da muss
man direkt also das so dass dieses team
bleiben
richtig gestellt hat diesmal ging warum
räumt mag es nicht weitergehen du
bleibst auch schön locker
ich musste meine sozialstunden machen
ich habe keinen bock auf nazis so
richtig gut
sie heißt dieses thema müssen wir diesen
modus reinkommt wie dabei nicht
hinterfragen sachen machen die personen
zwölf jahre 30 ist mit meiner familie in
deutschland und wir versuchen zu
integrieren und wie gehe sogar zum
deutschunterricht und jannis zuhause
deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum tom
und edgar und so dumm gemein an machen
diese verzweiflung die aus ihrer stimme
raus klingt wenn ihre stimme ein
gesichtsausdruck und die kennen die nato
schon mit namen natürlich immer da man
ist ja in engen kontakt geflüchtet
dann sitzen wir zusammen
ich wollte mich nur noch einmal
entschuldigen für die aktion gestern
freuen kapital noch keine massiven
ehrlich zu sein kommt das nächste mal
wenn sie mal habe ich schon gemacht
vielleicht grießmann an jedes gibt es
auch schon
die gewalt die die erste landwirt
gesessen sind meine lieben diese kirche
ist perfekt hätte müssen wissen wie das
ist wenn man andere absteigen ehrenstein
[Musik]
warum also das klar was gemeint ist aber
nicht wirklich sagen so mein kleiner
bruder soll warum liegt er da sollte
nicht im krankenhaus wenn du so was
kommt egal was jetzt sagt ich bin so
etwas wie wird sie ganz anders gekommen
dass ich bin sofort wieder sagen
jetzt kommt ins spiel ich habe endlich
ein ende gefunden mein nächstes soll ein
papier das handy aber das muss echt
unter uns bleiben wenn meine freunde das
erfahren wir nicht so dramatisch wie
sollte jetzt handy-kamera habe ich die
nazis das handy geklaut
warum hat er das wissen nimmt das handy
aber okay diese müsse darüber sprechen
[Musik]
nein ich hätte gar nicht gedacht dass
wir das ja nie wieder bekommen
richtig ernst ich hätte gar nicht
gedacht dass wir das in die idm bekommen
ohne willst so oft das ist richtig
schlecht gespielt aber die scheiß
einfach drauf
es gibt sogar viel probieren es wirklich
bis meister schauspieler sie scheiße
einfach nein ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass wir das handy wiederbekommen
da ist noch was vor
vielleicht will ja nicht einfach nur
verarschen ich habe keineswegs
gesprochen habe
wir müssen den suchen du weißt was papa
gesagt hat zu uns es war papas
wunschteam einzuladen
da braucht es so akzent ist kann gefällt
es war papa sting einzuladen
glaubt mir niemand niemand seine
kollegen wieder die nazis trinken wir
feiern aber wieder wird nichts und da
kommt wirklich so ein meter davor auf
der straße so gibt es keine nazi clubs
das erlaube aktiv.de freunde waren das
die lukas lukas konto dafür hängt mit
richtigen okay das macht so was nicht
[Musik]
das ist mein kapital bleibt denn die
masse komischen bieten
was macht die wanderwege gewohnt ja das
ist die frage
also warum sollten sie sozusagen sein
und macht immer noch da sein
ja mach schneller ich möchte jetzt
eigentlich nach hause
der lädt dich zu uns ein
es kommt jetzt ist also der kanzler auch
ganz kurz so kapital ist auch einfach
nicht getötet der situation immer so
einen hass blickte ich muss ja arbeiten
ich musste das tor
ich weiß nicht als findig sein das
übertrieben aber hast du schon mal
gemeint als jemand gesagt hätte keine
homepage überhaupt nur angetreten
ich kann mir nicht ich muss aber
klassiker zu stressig und da hinten in
der platte eigentlich das ist ein
grosses gebäude plattenbau hat hinter
mir ja ja das ist ausgeübt haben musst
gebäude plattenbau straße gewicht ja ich
hab mir jetzt seine argumente angehört
und ok kurz überlegt die körperteile 70
kilogramm
das wasser im ersten teil von dieser
folge und vom ersten video in 2009/10
morgen kommt der nächste teil check ist
ein unding hier ein für euch persönlich
vorgeschlagen das video ab und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder biss dann